[موسيقى]
بالفعل عبد القادر هذا الانفجار الضخم
الذي حصل قبل ثوان معدوده حقيقه هو ياتي
في المناطق الجنوبيه او الضواحي الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه انفجار ضخم لم يكن ناجما عن
غارات جويه او عن قصف المدفعيه لكن يبدو
انه كان تفجيرا انبعث من باطن الارض وهذا
ما يرجع على ان ما جرى هناك هو تفجير
متعمد قام به الجيش الاسرائيلي ل مجموعه
كما يبدو من المنازل القريبه من السياج
الامني او المجمعات السكنيه كما هو الحال
في كل المناطق الشرقيه التي تتعرض لتدمير
كبير وممنهج من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الاسابيع الاخيره في اطار السعي لاقامه
منطقه امنيه عازله تحديدا تلك في تلك
المناطق القريبه من السياج الامني ومن
البلدات الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه نحن نسمع
الان ايضا تجدد الق قصف المدفعي الشديد
على الاطراف الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وهنالك
ايضا حقيقه اشتباكات في المناطق الشماليه
للقطاع في بيت لاهيه وفي بيت حنون نسمع
بين الحين والاخر اشتباكات على الاقل
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله وتترافق ايضا مع
قصف
مدفعي اذا نسمع مزيد من التفجيرات حقيقه
وهي عبد القادر غير ناجمه عن غارات جويه
او قصف متف
كما هو كما كان الحال على الاقل في
الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم من
الواضح بان قوات الهندسه الاسرائيليه تعمل
على تفخيخ
وتفجير المباني القريبه من السياج الامني
كما حصل في المغازي عندما قتل 21 ضابطا
وجنديا عندما كانت تتحضر الفرقه لتفجير
مجمع سكني كبير في منطقه المغازي والان
شاهدنا في الدقائق الاخيره تفجير كبير وقع
في المنطقه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه كان
تفجيرا كبيرا وهائل يبدو انه استهدف تدمير
مجمع سكني كبير في تلك المناطق لان
الانفجار كان قد انبعث من باطن الارض ولم
يكن ناجما عن غاره جويه ونحن كنا نشاهد مع
الزميل لبيب ايضا حجم الدمار الكبير الذي
خلفته الاله العسكريه الاسرائيليه حقيقه
في كل الضواحي الشر
لقطاع غزه تحديدا تلك القريبه من منطقه
الغلاف وتحديدا تلك التي هي قريبه من
البلدات الاسرائيليه كما كنا نقول نشاهد
طبعا هذا الدمار يطال الاف المباني
السكنيه حقيقه لكن اذا ما ضربنا كل مبنى
في ثلاث او اربع طوابق نحن نتحدث عن ربما
عشرات الاف الشقق السكنيه التي تم تدميرها
بشكل ممنهج وبشكل تام و وبالتالي اصبحت
غير قابله للسكن وعوده الفلسطينيين اليها
فيما اذا سمح لهم بذلك في قادم الايام
مناطق بكاملها تم محوها عن وجه الارض
ودمرت تدميرا شديدا لم تعد قابله للسكن
ولا للعيش والجيش الاسرائيلي يبدو انه
يخطط لاقامه منطقه عازله تمدد تمتد في عمق
كيلومتر الى كيلومتر ونصف نحن نشاهد حجم
الدمار الكبير في تلك المناطق حقيقه ونحن
تتحدث بالفعل عن كيلومتر تقريبا من
المنطقه الحدوديه التي تشهد هذا التدمير
المنهجي والمتعمد من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اطار اقامه هذه المنطقه
العازله التي لم تقنع حقيقه عبد القادر
بعد الاسرائيليين بالعوده الى منازلهم في
البلدات الاسرائيليه تحديدا تلك القريبه
من السياج الامني الجيش الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه عقدت اكثر من اجتماع
مع رؤساء البلديات في هذه المنطقه وحاولوا
حثهم
واقناعهم للعوده الى البلدات الاسرائيليه
لاعاده الاسرائيليين الى منازلهم على
اعتبار ان الكلفه الاقتصاديه ايضا هي
كبيره بالنسبه للحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن
الاسرائيليين رفضوا العوده الى منازلهم
على اعتبار انهم يشاهدون القتال الذي ما
ما زال جري وهو ضاري حقيقه في تلك المناطق
وايضا المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي ما زالت
قادره على ضرب الغلاف بالصواريخ